فرق العاصمة المكسيكية مع
ناطحات السحاب في الأحياء الغنية
في يوم صاف ، يمكنك رؤيتها من
حي سان غريغوريو على بعد
أميال قليلة فقط
ولكن هنا لا توجد ثروة ولا توجد
مياه جارية
، ولهذا السبب يتعين على فيكتوريا أرياس لوبيز
النزول إلى هذه البراميل
تتركها الحكومة أربعة منهم
كل 15 يومًا وهو أمر غير آمن لشرب
الكوانتوس دياز نوس نوسوتروس ،
لذا فإن ما تقوله هو
أن الدلاء التي
لديها الماء ينفد أساسًا في
غضون ثلاثة أيام كحد أقصى
، جزء كبير من راتبها الضئيل  يذهب
لشراء المياه المعبأة للشرب ، أما بالنسبة
للملابس ، تقع محطة الغسيل
على بعد 15 دقيقة بالسيارة حيث
تساعد الحنفية الحكومية في شطف رغوة الصابون ،
ليس لدينا الكثير من الماء ، يقول سنورا
لوسيرو ، يعاني الجميع هنا
من نقص المياه ،
لذا  كثير من الناس في هذه المنطقة ليس لديهم
مياه جارية ، ومع ذلك فإنك ترى حملات حكومية في
كل مكان تقول:
اغسل يديك
باستمرار وهذا أمر جيد  نصيحة أثناء الجائحة ،
ولكن إذا لم يكن لديك مياه جارية ،
فكيف من المفترض أن تفعل بالضبط تلك
البيانات الحكومية تظهر أن ما يقرب من 20
بالمائة من المدينة لا يحصلون
على المياه كل يوم
في الغالب في أفقر أجزاءها وهم من
بين المناطق  التي عانت من معظم
الحالات
مع استمرار انتشار الفيروس ،
لم تفهم الحكومة أنها تقول
فيكتوريا هناك مياه في الأجزاء الغنية
ولكن ليس هنا ،
فهي تعيش في هذا المنزل مع 12
شخصًا آخر يجمعون مياه الأمطار أثناء
نزولها من  يستقر السقف المتسخ
في هذه الدلاء ، إنه متسخ
جدًا للشرب أو
الغسل دون أن يقولوا اغسل يديك
جيدًا في كثير من الأحيان ، ليس لدينا ما يكفي من الماء
للقيام بذلك
، من المستحيل كما تقول
أو أنها فازت
بمسابقة وقمنا بزيارتها في اليوم  عندما
كانت Isla urbana غير الهادفة للربح تقوم بتركيب
نظام ترشيح جديد من
شأنه أن يجعل الماء نظيفًا بما يكفي
لغسله ومع مرشح آخر
آمن بما يكفي للشرب مما يعني تقليل
الخروج
من غسل اليدين وحماية أفضل
من
فيروس قد لا يبدو عليه ، لكن هذا نوع من
الرفاهية
لا يمتلك معظم جيرانها
أنهارًا غير لامع. CNN Mexico City